what's happening there kiddos we're
gonna watch ourselves gravity falls
episode 14 today if you can leave a like
that would be very much appreciated
subscribe and click that bell to get
notified when a reaction for the next
falls is up then boys at prepper thank
you for helping us edit down these
highlights you guys are all
solid people and also uh full length
watch alongs recycle but the time go for
gravity falls over at our patreon page
thank you to all those showing their
support by becoming super adjusted and
check out all the crap we gotta offer
over there
let's get to it i've said too much
[Music]
in this land of ours there are many
great pits but none more bottomless than
the bottomless pit which as you can see
here is bottomless
hmm grunkle stan why are we here again
to dispose of things that we don't want
so long mystery shack suggestion cards
oh no no
little gideon
die die
what are you doing throwing stuff dude
everyone's doing it
what you got there mabel it's just my
personal box of mysterious secrets
[Music]
oh no do i really have to be the one to
point out that a bottomless pit is by
definition impossible
says you
i guess we'll never know
oh no
some sort of invisible pushing force
quick everyone back to the shack back
back to the shack
here we go
and away we go
[Music]
something about the animation there
looked like
an earlier animation like an earlier
episode that they have redesigned for
this
it's like when you watch family guy
season four versus family guy season two
or early simpsons versus now simpsons
tracy allman simpsons
there's somewhere where it looks like
we're nowhere
[Music]
we're gonna land on something eventually
could be any second now
i want you to throw that down there well
it looks like we're down here for the
long haul who wants to see some card
tricks
[Laughter]
well done
fine
i'll tell you a story a story i'd like
to call
voiceover
oh my god this is an anthology episode
let's do it i think i just got bit by a
snake i need you to get me to a hospital
quick
sorry it's just hard to focus on what
you're saying with that squeaky puberty
voice you got there so my voice doesn't
crack but a crack so much we've already
made a techno remix out of it my name's
dipper pines
oh
do i really sound like that oh here
comes my favorite part stop it guys
[Music]
even my size sound weird hello there
i couldn't help but overhear your
situation old man mcgucket
part-time inventor yeah lately i've been
a tinkerizing with a voice altering
tonic on account of my horrifying voice
this will really fix my voice thanks
you're gonna sound like him come morning
you'll sound like a new man
good morning dipper
nice i love it
no i have a new voice
oh it's so weird who's my favorite mabel
i knew boys voices changed but this is
weird just think of the prank calls this
is the president of the united states of
america i'm calling to tell you
what who is this
magnificent
how you diddly doing zeus
i thought you'd like the new one dude at
least before you sounded like a real
person
oh
grunkle stan where are you grunkle stan
this guy you're the guy who prank called
me earlier oh [ __ ] no no i'm not i'm
just a 12 year old boy
i.e
there's a prank call around the loose
let's get him
your invention was a catastrophe that's
probably why i live in the dump
i got tap skills well now here's your
problem i gave you the wrong
drinkie-ma-jig this one's for voice-over
professional uh-huh come sundown you'd
have reverted back to your ridiculous
old voice it was ridiculous wasn't it
yes
zipper your voice one of a kind dude
i've never heard anything like it
remix over
this one should be permanent
[Music]
hey guys
i guess i realized that even though my
voice might not be perfect it's still
mine and i wouldn't change it for
anything not even for whatever was in
this new vial so what did you do with
the rest of that potion i dumped it in
stan's coffee put my girdle there all
right
i'm grunkle stan
head movement
everyone spin no
[Laughter]
[Music]
dipper's pain is funny but i'm starting
to get bored
this story is called zeus's really great
pinball story
is that a good title they have to be
like puns or whatever
[Laughter]
i might finally get the high score on
stan's creepy old pinball machine have
you ever tried maybe just tilting the
machine i don't know dudes isn't
breaking the rules like against the
rules
failure you stink all right that's it
ready kids
wowie
oh ah this is the best moment of my life
this totally beats my old best moment
ah
i want that experience you cheated oh
yeah what are you gonna do about it uh
guys there's an awful lot of green
lightning coming out of that game ah
that's the normal amount of green
lightning
dude you can get a tooth like that guy
dude that's that's my goal i get told
him to give me the
seuss inside the game
crazy sweet most cool
that's incredible if this is a dream i
never want to wake up
that could be your right his tooth
oh yeah
i want to be a one gold tooth guy that's
my goal
i feel like i got to earn it if and i do
recall i warned y'all not to cheat i
tried to be gentlemanlike but i'm plum
sick of being tilted no i'm gonna tilt
you
well take this
ah get yourselves ready for the
oh that's dangerous always sounds more
fun than it is how are we ever gonna get
out of here think guys i'm trying but
it's hard with that gorgeous pinball
wench distracting me
working magic there's a manual power
switch inside i could sneak in there and
turn off the game but we'll have to
distract the cowboy guy
[Music]
what's going on just press the switch
already okay so i was gonna do that but
i've been thinking according to this
turning off the power erases the high
score permanently oh my god man you
cheated
get ready to meet your maker kids my
maker is hallway games in redmond
washington my thing it's a good
combination of valleys in midway
[Music]
come on buddy
goodbye high score
[Music]
huh hey man i'm sorry you had to lose
your high score that's okay i got a new
life accomplishment now saving you dudes
oh
i'll tell you a good story it's called
grunkle stan wins the football ball
[Music]
i thought old folks were useless but you
taught me and my gloating friends a
lesson
awesome but i couldn't have done it
without my sidekick
footbot thank you for building me daddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm gonna tell a non-terrible story a
story called trophy oh no that can't be
good it's a good title truly good title
card
so let me get this straight your plan is
to teach this bear to ride a bicycle no
no i'm gonna teach this bear
to drive ooh yeah
oh no
and the yellow light means speed up
green means stop her red means stop
green beans go yellow beans go very fast
you see i'm a very old man and the
doctors assigned me a seeing eye bear to
drive me to the hospital in case of
emergencies then where's your doctor's
note
ah there you go
uncle stan how could you lie to those
police ah when you get to be my age
you'll learn that sometimes you have to
bend the truth for the greater good hey
has anyone seen my plate of spaghetti
no but i bet zeus has
this is a dark day
oh
great or good
no
wow good core work he needs to stop
lying i know but how do we stop them
maybe you should check dipper's journal
oink oink water you genius
one of the wattles is just a recurring
character now the deep forest are truth
teeth which force upon the wearer and
inability to lie
hmm
jim carrey dentures
[Music]
what happened to dipper's spaghetti
plate
i hate it because i have little to no
concern for other people's possessions
or emotions
that was strangely candid almost as if
i'm unable to lie
this is bad what do you do in secret
every day during your lunch break
usually i spend the hour aggressively
scratching myself in places i shouldn't
mention oh and go to the bathroom
without washing my hands oh
i said that don't worry dipper the truth
is always a good thing no
do you think this t-shirt is my size
never mind the t-shirt hey everybody
look at this guy's abnormal and
unattractive face
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry looks like a
weeple
[Music]
[Laughter]
is life just some kind of horrific joke
without a punchline that we're all just
biting our time into the sweet sweet
release of death
[Laughter]
existential stan you have to take those
teeth out of his mouth but then he'd be
a liar again could it possibly be any
worse than this
so after further investigation turns out
you see i lied to you in addition i've
been parking in handicap spaces
shoplifting fireworks and smuggling
endangered animals across multiple state
lines and speeding
[Laughter]
no no it's not true
right mabel our green uncle stan is
is
[Music]
uh
he was just telling you about a
character from his upcoming page turner
crime grandpa he's never committed a
crime in his life also
have you lost weight
smooth i can't believe i lied mabel it
was for the greater good hello police
station yeah i forgot to tell him about
my tax fraud
no tag
i really enunciate there you have to
find a place to get rid of these
[Music]
and i never saw that box full of magical
teeth again
there must be an answer in there
and the shoes
oh sweet my shoes so if we're living
through that story right now then how
does it end guys do you see that
the bottom
this is gonna spit them right back out
again
oh the sky
yeah
we came right back out the top it must
be some kind of wormhole but that's
impossible no one will believe us sell
tickets we should keep to
ourselves agreed
dude what a perfect ride this would be
for for mystery shack patrons that's so
boring but it's gonna be so boring
reminds me of bill and ted just
this is stupid
where all those numbers oh every episode
at the end of the credits apparently has
a cipher that you can solve
oh yeah
so you know
you'd like to take the time to do that
i don't got time for riddles
the answer's justice
it's gonna be forever that now
what was your favorite one
uh i think my favorite story overall
for story purposes was the godfather two
was the godfather two best movie of all
time uh you can fight me about it uh way
better than the original movie not quite
as good as the third one but it's my
personal favorite
uh i think the pinball story
is my favorite from an aesthetic point
of view because i
donald m humphrey love pinball dearly
it's my favorite kind of
arcade game
um why are you so terrible at it
you know because i only get to play like
once every so often when i wind up near
a pinball machine because that's the
hardest kind of game to get in your home
without it being like on the computer
and then it doesn't count
you know you are and i'm awful at
pinball i
i just have a passion for it and i it's
not about the points
uh
you know i just like to put quarters and
stuff you know one time there's like a
group of us who are just drinking our
beer and just watching josh you know
fail uh
he's so awful just all the different
pictures you're the first person i ever
saw getting awarded with new lowest
themes
was still distinct in that game's arena
you know i proved myself in a way
that's also uh an extreme superlative i
believe in an underdog story but once in
a while you gotta learn it was an over
dog story i was like how can i sing to
the bottom here
most compellingly
ah truth be told i've never seen john
play pinball once in a while he's
missing out missing out i think i've
seen him play space pinball is what
you're talking i walk in the room i'm
like you know like there are cool angles
and stuff and then i start playing
quietly on my own but then an hour later
pretty soon everyone in the bar is like
around me like what's this guy doing
this where is he gonna put that ball
what's he gonna sign his name as when he
only has three letters to do it
yeah
that's also a fact
do you go with poo what do you go with
jew jew that's a three letter word yeah
plus then if anybody sees it they'll
just assume that like any and all jewish
people are probably responsible for that
high score so like the entire
you know jewish people are represented
content
contents
so yeah sue's pinball for for my
personal heart probably stand for a
narrative you know uh
narrative purpose
what about you
who's your favorite part or story or
moment
it's definitely the truth ache
i think that is a brilliant title that's
a brilliant title it is
for especially you know considering what
the concept is
like that is clever yeah
i don't i think you guys are
underestimating the wittiness
that title plus the ability it allows
you to to then you know have the
stylized spelling of the word truth
that is genius
line yeah it's great great visual genius
storytelling purpose wonderful
i was
genuinely impr alone off of the title
and the title card
was dazzled
by
that surely that is smart surely it is
yeah and then they just did like liar
liars yes
yeah yeah
but that title card
yeah and plus you know i always love
that motif in any cartoon show we don't
get as much with a show like this that
usually has one story would you get
three little title cards like a classic
cartoon
fair you know
plus
fair this episode was probably very
affordable
because half of it
had no backgrounds it was also uh well
executed for you know to do an anthology
episode
tell four stories
three three and like
round
yeah yeah
because stan is just like a quick little
vignette but to tell that amount of
stories and and like to have a beginning
middle on end in
20 minutes it's pretty impressive yeah
it's pretty impressive so i had a little
bit more than like a little bit more
like sitcom punchy yeah yeah yeah
there's not as much time to build gags
off of situations yeah yeah but i really
like the deep voice one uh for some
reason the pinball one while
aesthetically i like the most i was
actually the least entertained by that
one i would probably meet you there
because the first one has the the
silliness of the voice that just works
across the board yeah and it's very
relatable yeah and then the third one
you know there's some some funny writing
i think in the third one but yeah the
pinball is the most straightforward
i don't love i forgot his name
suze i don't love zeus that much oh i do
i love zeus i like zeus
i know when you say you don't love zeus
that much is you hate the show you hate
the show and everything it's about that
yeah i don't watch it ago
i can't no don't bring him back on
screen
but i don't personally gravitate towards
zeus but i like him that's fair
i like him i just i just uh he's the
least
never excited to see him
nor am i disappointed when he's not
featured yeah
just like i could give or take without
that guy but he had some funny moments
in here i might who knows we might get a
seuss episode at some point
hmm
seuss's juices
hey that's a great title there yeah you
want to talk about a truth ache that's a
good ass title and plus nothing top
truth imaginable well you know
yeah oh brilliant those would be like
weird body over there yeah i did what is
this episode his teeth gonna be kind of
like teeth
scary horror plus teeth is very skin
crawling you know it's very unnerving
what about horror plus butts
dude there's a lot of i mean it's not
the most mainstream but when you get
like a particularly nasty horror butt
gag it's it's
very very squirmy as well in a totally
different way what about that attack of
the butts book i borrowed from you dude
i never got it back it was a good dude
is it worth it i just put it in a book
burning [ __ ] my butt ran away or
whatever it's called yeah yeah dude i
should i am going to order another copy
of this they're probably
they're probably probably good wills
everywhere
yeah
i want to see that brought to life here
i think some disembodied butts i mean
there was absolutely nothing with
realistic butts there was a show real
like just real like some are different
like hairy hairless big small flat
yeah
bubbly bubbly onion booties yeah yeah
there was a show on adult swim
called assy mcgee
about there's a real cop cartoon about a
cop
who was like legs who was an ass and he
had just legs and he walked backwards
because his ass was his face and out of
the cheeks came arms and he had like a
gun and and this is a real show you can
watch for a season or two's worth
of a cop show called assy mcgee so like
you know part of part of your wish has
already come true but i think he was the
only
butt guy in that show you know
so speaking of butts butts
eric horstmann when i think about who
would our patreon has a good butt but
more importantly wouldn't cancel us for
talking about your butt
it's eric
i'm pretty sure you're the only one
who would let us talk about your butt
yeah
i would love to to see you in like a
form-fitting pair of spandex tights or
something like that yeah i would love to
just get a sculpture like a wax
sculpture put it above my fireplace
in my future four-story mansion
when people walk in and they see that
sculpture like who's that mounted on a
fine piece of mahogany they're like not
right there
great horseman ass the horseman are
sources
you gotta be supposed to yes
yeah and so yeah anyway eric i've
seriously been contemplating i have this
wish in my head it's a really morbid
wish but it's also so sweet oh my god if
i vlog did we get so many views
now i gotta do it in private to look
humble that's not a [ __ ]
but it's that you're dying in the
hospital
and then i get a real rejects tattoo but
i put your name in there oh you got real
rejection
visit you i would vlog it and you get
the tattoo
on your butt
no it's gotta be on my arm so that way
people will ask get in the eye oh my god
you're so so
sweet you don't show yourself you're
like the best human ever such a
charitable greg
oh my god dude
oh that would just elevate your status
in this world that much more i know as
eric wait until i get canceled and then
i'm gonna do that
that's the plan
see greg's a good person he's changed he
he dedicated his arm space to this one
guy who's dying sarah you have saved us
from cancellation cancel proof eric
horseman great as ours
[Music]
you